the thing that the left has done very
very effectively is claimed to have a
monopoly on morality because it defines
morality in quite a narrow way itself it
has to be essentially rationally
calculable but actually if you think
about it a lot a lot of what we actually
do that is moral is actually very
sentimental and habitual right we didn't
think about it we just do it because
it's the right thing to do and so if you
are actually taking principles like
Freedom inequality well actually you can
destroy the family with those principles
you know you don't owe anything to your
parents and you can't say that your your
father is superior to you because that's
not equality and so you're you're not
bound by being you didn't choose your
parents but you and so by the the
principles of Freedom equality can be
Unbound from your own family and like
children can have no responsibility to
not only their parents but their own
country and to anything like that it's
like God this is actually quite horrific
call you Carl or do I call you a Sargon
of akkad now that we are officially
sitting down once again after many years
I think Carl will do Carl will do all
right there is a lot I want to talk
about with you and I said to you right
before we started of all weeks for you
to be in America because you live across
the pond You Came the very week that
we're opening up the studio to in-person
guests and for people who do not know
who haven't been with me since the
beginning of the beginning when I was
waking up to the left what's going on
with the left why are we calling
everybody racist no one's actually
acting liberally yeah the Sargon of a
Cod story everybody online all the
commenters said Dave you got to watch
this guy Sargon of a cot I don't know
that your face was even in the video
but everybody said you gotta watch
Sargon because I started watching your
videos and I'm going wow this guy's a
liberal and he makes sense and then
eventually we started talking you had me
on your show and in some ways the rest
is history so I think I've done it once
or twice over the years but I give you
serious cred uh for getting me here
today because you were one of the first
in that way so
tell give the people like the two-minute
bio about you first and then we'll get
into the politics and the fighting and
the craziness and the state of the world
and the rest yeah yeah and welcome to
the free state of Florida it's beautiful
it's so much nicer than California it's
Greenery around right I'm from England
so if I'm I'm not surrounded by Greenery
yeah I get a bit weird and edgy and
California is just this brown blasted
hellscape of dirt whereas Florida it's
luscious genuinely luscious um speaking
of my language it's crazy because I was
the same though in for me it happened in
about 2012 2013 where I was just I
wasn't even like a hard liberal I was
just like well no I'm a liberal person
and I believe in you know basic liberal
ideals which most of us really do even
even the quite conservative people will
say well actually yeah I mean obviously
I want rule of law freedom of speech and
property rights and all these sorts of
things right fairly fairly basic stuff
so it's not stuff we had to think about
too often and then we had this very
aggressive and what I now after the fact
have learned is just essentially open
communist Insurrection within liberalism
and at the time they weren't publicly
like that you know it's it's actually
been quite far on that you've got Hassan
paiker being like yes I'm a communist
here's my red flag you know beneath
behind him which is you know okay fair
enough at least at least it masks off
right because before they would say I'm
a liberal but everything around you is
racist and we need to redistrute all the
wealth season the property that's that's
not very liberal oh that's refreshing to
hear that they're giving up the mantle
of liberalism that would be nice that
would be nice because they're actually
the most illiberal people on the planet
of course and and they know it as well
that's the thing they are well aware
that they're just like right okay what
can we do to kind of explode liberalism
from the inside and honestly they've
done a good job of it but wait before we
get to them and everything else so so
it's 2011 2012. you're saying you know
I'm just kind of a
liberal guy but now you're doing some
stuff on YouTuber what what was waking
you up that kind of get into this I was
trying to develop a video game and
obviously being in that sort of space
you start becoming aware of like well
feminism frankly coming in and attacking
the industry as a whole and I was just
like okay what is this I looked into it
and I was like okay this isn't really in
line with the principles basically
everyone is espousing why are we why are
we stigmatizing men and of course then
that leads on to the stigmatization of
white people and straight people and
anything that they view is what they
call a dominant class it gets
stigmatized in order to try and tear it
down and so I started making videos just
in 2013 it was July 2013. it's my first
video where I was just like look I don't
really agree with this and I don't
really understand why you're saying it
and I think and
looking back right I watched my very
first video a few years ago man I was
naive
well we all were we are right yeah
because and we were we generally it was
like okay why don't I just explain why I
think you're wrong and then we'll have a
discourse and they were like oh you're a
misogynist and I was like oh you know
and I was outraged the first time I was
called a misogynist I was genuinely
outraged because of course I'm not a
misogynist you know why would you even
say that it's fair for me to have a
critique of your philosophy and like no
you just hate women it's like oh right
okay you know but of course you know the
duck water off of ducks back these days
because you can't critique black lives
matter feminism or anything about being
an istanophobe you know obviously that's
become very apparent that they just use
that as a sort of defense mechanism to
try and shut you up but I think that
really that's that time has passed I
think everyone Ten Years Later the uh
the words don't matter as much as they
used to back then exactly everyone's
like immune to that kind of attack now
and and yeah and so I just started
talking about these things from my
perspective which really is still the
perspective of a classical liberal you
know I've I've I've developed an
appreciation of conservatism like real
sort of hearthy conservatism you know
the sort of genuine sort of bonds of
sentiment that tie together people and
place and Community Building outwards
the nation into Humanity you know I've
really spent a lot of time reading their
philosophy because they're actually
really bad at articulating it you know
you you probably can't actually name
very many conservative philosophers but
you can name dozens of left-wing ones
right you know and so it's kind of
annoying that the conservatives are
actually quite bad at telegraphing their
message it's actually it's a really
wholesome message you know really what
the most what's the most important thing
in your life well your family actually
the people who depend on you know and so
I've kind of been leaning into that a
bit more but you know I've still got the
same sort of classical liberal core
where it's like well obviously people
should be treated as individuals in
decent ways but there's more to the good
life than just being an atomized
individual on your own you know with
just a bunch of things given to you by
the state there's actually a lot more to
the good life than that
um and so yeah I just continued
developing I've matured a lot and which
is never fun to say right yeah because
it's it's you know you realize it
depends where you end up I suppose well
yeah yeah but it's it's never fun to say
but I've definitely matured a lot and I
started a business called loadsees.com
where we develop
um sort of I I hate to say it's
right-wing philosophy but like I don't
really have a better term for it you
know because everything else seems to be
well left-wing philosophy so okay well I
guess you know but what we're really
trying to do is just properly understand
the sort of metaphysics of what it is we
actually assume all day every day
because we never talk about the
importance of not just family because
it's easy to say then it's trite say
this okay what about the family actually
isn't this important and it's really the
bonds of reliability on the person right
because one one thing having four kids
has taught me it's the predictability of
each day is what's really good for your
children it's really what they need they
need to wake up and know Dad's going to
do this mum's gonna do this I'm gonna go
to school and everything will be the
same as it was yesterday and will be the
same tomorrow and so they can genuinely
be happy in the world around them and
then when you start thinking like this
you're a nice card the people in charge
are totally irresponsible with
everything in our state you know
everything in the country everything in
the west you know they're just so
Cavalier with the decisions that they
make and it's like God how can they
think like this and I think a lot of it
is because we've kind of Lent too much
towards liberalism and not enough
towards what should be a happy marriage
between liberalism and conservatism
I'm with you brother right I feel it I
get it it's why now I say to my I say to
my audience I can call myself a
conservative I I'm married to a man
that's not very conservative in in the
sense that it would have been thought of
say 50 years ago but I do believe in the
family and I believe in the importance
of community and things like that do you
think that you sort of hinted at this
but do you think that liberalism had an
inherent flaw that allowed The
Barbarians at the gate and then kind of
to open the door to the gate or open the
door to the castle the the problem the
problem with liberalism and so I I spent
a lot of time reading and researching
into liberalism itself as a philosophy
because so much of it goes unsaid right
we we assume the truth of all of the
presuppositions underpin liberalism but
actually there are some real flaws with
it and one of the main things I took
away from it is that liberalism is an
incomplete philosophy right it's not a
philosophy for Life what it is is kind
of a way of recognizing when the state
is going too far right when you are
being actively oppressed which we've
seen recently in the example of Russell
Brand actively being persecuted I mean
what what's happening to Russell brown
but the British government at the moment
is a violation of article 39 of Magna
Carta yeah like a man without the lawful
Judgment of his peers under the law of
the land shall not be transgressed upon
oppressed upon by the state that's
literally what it says and it and this
is what we're watching happening in real
time so it's it's not enough to just be
a liberal but liberalism is great in
that regard in that sort of narrow band
it's really good to say look these are
these are the rules and the boundaries
that have been kind of learned from
English political tradition and then
that way they can be spread around the
world brilliant idea
but on the other side it lacks a kind of
normative Doctrine as in you know you
get up here what should you do today and
actually liberalism doesn't have any
answers to this and so this gives the
whole world of what we're conservatives
and Christians in particular have lots
of good answers for what you should do
today no you should get up what you
should make your kids breakfast you
should get in school you should go to
work you should uphold the right
ordering of the world in your actions in
the character of what you do
and liberalism really can't say that and
so that's why liberalism is kind of
vulnerable because if actually you take
away the Christianity take away the
conservative values then you can take
the liberal principles of Freedom
equality and say right I can explode
these out to everything you know the
freedom to never be
bothered by another human being so
you're just an isolated individual who's
there I'm free to take as many drugs as
I want I'm free to just become dependent
on the government oh we want equality
now right okay well how do you get a
quality well you've got to make sure the
lowest never have the highest never have
more than the lowest so you've got to
tax them to equality it's like well hang
on a second that's not good right or
just or fair I would say that's not
liberal but it's what liberalism is
devolved into you're basically saying
there was no there was no stop sign
along the way so it was sort of
inevitable that that this would happen
once you take away all the other
considerations about like the richness
of human life then actually you can take
liberal principles and explode them into
things they're not meant to be you know
and this is the problem I think that the
left has right now and why so many
people are just like okay I used to be
part of the left but I'm not that so I
guess it doesn't shock you then when you
look back and you go okay you were doing
these videos saying hey liberals wake up
and then a guy like Dave Rubin from the
very far left Young Turks is kind of
waking up and then he's talking to you
and then we've seen a Siri you know Bill
Maher kind of half wakes up we get a
series of people that kind of wake up a
lot of them end up going back the other
way because the mob freaks them out and
they can't they're not brave enough okay
but I guess you think that it's sort of
just like an inevitability of a liberal
who's really thinking right or something
like that I would say it's about
intellectual honesty and moral courage
um because there are lots of people who
are
in a very sort of cloying Society in
places like California whether it's very
oppressive like for all of the freedom
that they claim to have actually you
don't have the freedom to say I disagree
and this I think is really the
fundamental precept of what Freedom
could be if you're not free to disagree
with what everyone else is doing then
how in what way are you really free and
I'm it was probably only a matter of
time until people like yourself people
like me turn around and said hang on no
I just don't agree with the way that you
view the world I don't agree with what
you're doing and I am willing to shed
the label of being left wing if it means
living an authentic life true to my
values and Truth what I believe is
correct and right and good and I think
there are a lot of people who frankly
lack that moral courage yeah they're
still that do you think part of
that it's not just that they're afraid
of the ma but there's something so baked
into culture the default of culture that
is left and I know these terms are sort
of becoming increasingly meaningless
which is nice to an extent but that
that's what they're really afraid of
like it's automatically like oh if
you're not for Equity if you're if you
don't think boys or girls you're
automatically framed as a bad guy now
and that people just don't want to walk
from that yeah I think um
okay
the
the thing that the left has done very
very effectively is claimed to have a
monopoly on morality because it defines
morality in quite a narrow way itself it
has to be essentially rationally
calculable but actually if you think
about it a lot a lot of what we actually
do that is moral is actually very
sentimental and habitual right we didn't
think about it we just do it because
it's the right thing to do and so if you
are actually taking principles like
Freedom inequality well actually you can
destroy the family with those principles
you know you don't owe anything to your
parents and you can't say that your your
father is superior to you because that's
not equality and so you're you're not
bound by being you didn't choose your
parents but you and so by the the
principles of Freedom equality can be
Unbound from your own family and like
children can have no responsibilities
not only their parents but their own
country and to anything like that it's
like God this is actually quite horrific
right and and this is a sort of radical
form of morality this is really unusual
like nowhere else on Earth and even even
you know from very very
um
sort of loose civilizations where the
society isn't very tightly knit to you
know deeply tribal societies where
literally everyone in the tribe is sort
of like the second or third cousins or
something you know everything outside of
left-wing morality is kind of on a
Continuum it has been normal for almost
all human societies to some degree for
all of human for all the time and it's
only since about the French Revolution
incidentally where this kind of radical
morality asserts itself and says right
this is the left and this is the
absolute liberation of the individual
really ultimately what they want is from
the flesh itself right and this is why
they're stigmatizing the body now oh
that child needs transition it's like
are you mad you know there's no way a
child can give informed consent to
transition they can't get informed
content get a loan yeah yeah
they can't chop off their own genitals
you Maniacs you know and so this this
radical liberatory morality is something
really quite new and it's you are right
it's not just the identity of the left
it's not just that the traffic I
actually think they're afraid that if
they kind of accept hang on a second I
bought into all of this wholesale then
what they're saying is I was being evil
actually and that's a really difficult
thing to look yourself in the mirror and
say oh everything I did was wrong every
time I cheered on a teenage girl who got
her breasts removed and stitched up I
was ruining someone's life actually and
so it's easier to say no everything else
about human morality is wrong and
oppressive and stigmatizing blah blah
and everything about this is just
perfectly good it's just they're bigots
it's a way easier thing to do than that
all right so you just gave me the
perfect segue to bring up something that
I've never talked about on this show and
in some ways I don't really want to talk
about but having you here I kind of feel
like I have to talk about it which is an
old colleague of mine at The Young Turks
Anarchist Varian who has said some
really really unbelievably horrible
dishonest things about me it's not
important actually I'm not going to
repeat any of them
um the internet sort of knows what they
are is what it is but we were extremely
good friends invited to my wedding etc
etc but apparently and I only know this
from some of the videos that you've done
uh she's having some sort of wake up
she's waking up out of this leftism and
this sort of mental prison that you're
describing
um you think you can get her over the
edge
I don't want to try
um because
it's been very embedded very publicly in
what I would call radical left-wing
morality for a very long time and
social knitson has this uh
particular quote that probably everyone
knows where the the a lot of the time
these people even when reality is
hitting them in the face with the
consequence of their own ideology they
won't admit it well actually uh Anna is
being hit in the face with the
consequences of this morality and it's
going okay I was wrong because she I
think she got assaulted by a homeless
person outside of a house I think that
she's very aware that uh the the trans
Lobby have got to the point where
they're going to degrade her status as
woman it's a merely birthing person or
something like that and
I'm sure she pays way too much in taxes
that Gavin Newsom I hear she's not a fan
of his policies right and so she's got
to the point where now it's affecting
her and it's like hang on a second
actually we need to arrest criminals
actually giving half my wages to the
state is not moral is not moral isn't
making the world a better place actually
a lot of the things are left to saying
such as uh there is no difference
between men and women uh these are not
truths right and you can't really build
morality on untruths actually and so I
think that she's come to the point where
it's untenable for her you know I think
I think that jenk is still essentially
wedded to the left and left-wing
morality and so I think he's afraid of
going of looking the reflection in the
mirror and saying look this is actually
kind of hideous it's kind of maybe uh
maybe the sort of Dorian Gray painting
might be a better thing right going and
look at the painting and look at the rot
on the face of the painting and being
like Oh my God is that secretly me in my
heart you know and so I I'm actually
tremendously sympathetic right and I
realize that that's not probably what
you would like to hear because she was
well you know she's been unbelievably
nasty and dishonest to me but I but I in
a weird way I am because I'm sympathetic
to people that are waking up to the
truth and I would want someone to get to
the end of the road and you know we
could still have some disagreements
about this that or the other thing and
I'm not expecting nor uh request an
apology
um but it would be nice to see someone
that has some influence waking up to
truth like that's pretty good A part of
me feels that she's kind of the victim
of the ideology
and I'm not trying to say that she's got
no agency or anything like that but well
she used to say but way back when that
you know when she got there at The Young
Turks she knew nothing about politics
and Jank taught her everything right and
so and if you're you know you're a host
on a massive Channel you've got
thousands and thousands of people every
day either reinforcing what your biases
are that you've been taught or
castigating you for having an
independent thought of your own you can
see how someone would well I'll just
move away from that and into the safe
place where I'm allowed to say left-wing
things and
I there's a part of me that I mean it
wasn't John Peterson who called it the
Mind virus
well now it's sort of everybody's saying
but I think Dad said he said it
originally that's correct yeah yeah the
parasitic mind was on it exactly yeah
exactly sorry cat
um
he's I think he's right to call it a
mind virus and I think that one when you
have a kind of disease it's not
necessarily your fault if you are in
ill-temper basically
um and so there's a part of me that is
that doesn't see her necessarily as
being the author of the actions she was
kind of operating in a pre-planned way
if someone is an apostate from leftism
that's worse than being a heretic you
know it's it's always worse to be the
apostate and so it's predictable that
she would act that way and one would
hope now that with her having a kind of
damascine moment of her own being like
hang on a second
these people are evil and wrong and then
cruel they're being cruel to me maybe
she'll think well in a way that I was
cruel to people I loved actually and
maybe
I owe them an apology was the most
shocking part to you as you were talking
about this stuff and and sort of seeing
the hate from you know your side so to
speak what I was more amazed by yes I
was shocked by the hate and I ended up
developing an autoimmune disease because
of it and lost like 40 of my hair I mean
I could not believe how much hate I was
getting from the supposed good guys so
I'm not saying that was nothing but the
thing that actually shocked me more so
and even to this day still shocks me in
a weird way is how conservatives who I
still might disagree with on some of the
social issues I'm begrudgingly
pro-choice
I'm married to a man as I said like
there might be some stuff there that my
life is not traditionally conservative
obviously
I get nothing but love from them nothing
but love and I am invited to religious
things of various denominations all the
time
um and I find them acting far more
liberally did that part shock you I mean
well is that a fair estimation for you
too that the conservatives who you were
probably disagreeing with maybe on taxes
at one point yeah and
in retrospect no but at the time yes yes
right because one of the things about
um conservative
this morality in itself is it it's very
concerned about if if you picture two
people who know each other you could
draw like you know Donnie Darko he's got
the sort of tunnel yeah yeah you could
draw one of those connecting the two
people right you can call that that
that's their relationship and that can
whack some Wayne and grow an intensity
so with my wife you know a very very
shining sort of connection because we
know each other very well you know we
love each other and we've got you know
lots of responsibility everything's very
bound up and so the conservatives are
very concerned about that and that is
maintained by Goodwill it's just
Goodwill it's about being polite to the
other person be caring doing acts of
unexpected kindness for the other person
you know you pick up some flowers for
your wife or you get you you take the
rubbish out or something right you don't
Rampage the city when you're protesting
how about that right they always clean
up when they're protesting exactly and
yeah exactly because that that sort of
Donnie Darko bond is everywhere to the
conservative they project it onto the
place they live and so they'll pick up
some rubbish off the street they won't
just throw rubbish on the floor right
because this this these love bonds that
come out of their chest they they s u I
think it's David Hume so we kind of
spread ourselves on the world around us
and that's totally true and that's what
the conservatives are like and so it
would shock me if a conservative wasn't
sensitive to that and so even if they
don't agree with you they still view you
as you you're not just a bad smell or a
bad thing to them you know and so
they'll treat you with respect and
decency and actually curiosity too which
liberals those are the ones that are
supposed to be curious but I found
conservatives they couldn't figure out
what to make of me at the beginning this
guy's a lefty he's gay like what's going
on here and then
but it actually is it actually they live
their lives by a code of decency whereas
the left has abandoned that they've said
no none of that is morality and so they
don't need to live their lives by a code
of decency sorry so but when you so when
you see now what's going on in LA in San
Francisco and I'm sure you guys have
some versions of it happening in the UK
like the places that that liberalism
fully took root which ultimately ended
up in this Progressive now communist
psychosis like it seems like the obvious
end game to you like or does or is it
not over there even like when you go to
San Francisco and see the devastation
can't get much worse than that I don't
think
it can always get worse and it is
getting worse that's the thing San
Francisco in fact is is probably a case
study of
um it's probably going to be in 50 years
time there'll be tragedies written about
San Francisco because I mean I was
talking to your your producers before
the show like they're too young to
remember but I remember when I was a
teenager San Francisco and Los Angeles
were legendary yes legendary like the
idea that anyone would leave voluntarily
leave these places is just mind-boggling
right but you can see how it's been
they've both been driven into the ground
I mean I was in San Francisco 2018 last
and even then it was like the zombie
apocalypse in here like you were walking
around there's literally zombified drug
users on the street and I was saying oh
my God I can't imagine way worse it is
now
um but it's it's
essentially the reduction of everything
good that's what the Communists want
they won't say that that's what they
want and they'll have some ideal but if
you have to equalize everything then the
only thing you can have is the lowest
common denominator so there's only one
way to go and that's down so would you
say from an American context our
Democrat Party and from a British
perspective your labor party are they
just like the party members and the
party Elites are they just using these
people as the as the Pawns in this game
or do you think they believe it too like
avenuesome destroyed San Francisco as
mayor then becomes governor of San of
California and in essence is destroying
California million people have left in
uh three years like what do you think
about the people that are actually in
charge just as a quick thing the labor
party in Britain has actually changed
um when when Jeremy corbyn was in charge
that it was exactly it was going that it
was exactly that kind of radical leftism
but actually kirst armor has kicked him
out of the party and kicked loads of his
supporters out of the party and
essentially stolen it back from the
radical left so actually the labor party
in Britain is more right-wing than the
conservative party is at the moment I
know it's crazy how would you say
they're more right-wing uh because they
they for example last year the
conservatives let in a million 1.2
million immigrants into the country well
under the labor party is constituted now
when they began the process of mass
immigration they topped off at about
half a million so actually the
conservatives are way worse and the
labor party will probably reduce the
overall amount of immigration is that
just bad governance by the conservatives
or it was like a plan to really let it I
mean I know I guess that's the endless
debate if I have an answer to that
question
um as far as I'm concerned the
conservative party is traitors right
weak-willed spineless traitors because
they're not really conservatives if they
were actually conservatives they would
just say no to a lot of things and
really that's the problem is we just
need an executive who will say no we're
not doing that no we're not doing that
no we're not doing that and that's
really all it's all it would take to
turn our civilizations around just have
the moral fortitude to just refuse when
a ridiculous this request is made it's
actually not that radical but the the
morality that overlays what we're
talking about it is a radical change
it'd be jetsoning the extreme left it
just sorry we're just not going to do
that we're not going to listen to you
anymore but going back to the Democrats
yeah totally captured and irredeemably
so it looks like
give me an idea I can smuggle in
tell me to do what happened with your
labor party I wish that was one well how
did it happen with with your well I
guess Corbin was so out of whack that
that maybe it became too with the labor
policy what it is there's there's a kind
of Old English Socialism or British
socialism that is rooted in these kind
of conservative mores where it's like no
where we love the country around us we
just want to have the National Health
Service we just want some social support
because we need it you know there are
there are poor people in the country who
need help and actually because we're a
small Old Country there's a lot more
sort of social texture there and so it's
easier to pull on that sort of it's a
lot more conservative and so the
traditional labor voters themselves are
insanely socially conservative like they
don't believe in any of this radical
leveling stuff and so corbyn had a bunch
of essentially students who supported
him and joined the party and uh kirstama
just got the vote of the majority of the
party was about two-thirds of the party
and he's he's not conservative but he's
not a radical leftist he's honestly he's
really not very bright uh so he's not
really anything but he's just doing what
he can do to get power right um and so
that's kind of what happened
in America honestly I really don't like
calling people evil right I don't like
saying oh that those people are just
malevolent right I don't like saying
that but it's really hard to be able to
formulate any other kind of reason why
someone like Gavin Newsom or Joe Biden
or whoever would just lie about what it
is that's happening they will tell
untruth about what you can see in front
of your very eyes and they'll say no
this is what progress looks like it's
like okay but progress looks like
literally the zombie apocalypse you know
I don't want whatever whatever you want
to call that I'm against it and I'm for
the complete opposite you know I'm for
growth and regeneration wholesomeness
and decency you are for literally giving
people drugs you know giving drug
addicts needles and it's not like you
don't see what happens because of it
he's got a long track record of what
happens because of it right it's
interesting because Biden I don't think
Biden is actually inherently evil I
think he's a deeply corrupt part of a
machine and he's been in it way too long
and he's completely mentally compromised
right now so I don't think he really
knows maybe how evil the machine is
using him something like that where
Newsom I think it's very clear he knows
what the outcome is and he is still
going for it so you don't see a way you
don't see I mean look RFK Jr I would say
is an old school liberal much like his
uncle and father and the party has
completely eliminated him yeah
absolutely I mean he he they've been
ruthless in the demonization of them as
well yeah because I didn't really know
anything about him to be honest you know
they won't put him on CNN now Jake
Tapper said he's too extreme he's too
extreme to interview him but he'll put
on DeSantis now obviously I don't think
DeSantis is Extreme but the point is
he's saying that the most conservative
guy I'll put him on but I won't have
this Democrat on and did you know this
that the the DNC has so rigged the
primary for Biden that if RFK shows up
in Iowa or any of the early primary
States the votes automatically go to
Biden because they know Biden doesn't
have to campaign so they're saying if
anyone else running shows up there the
votes go like so obvious it's so naked
and it's hard to say that these people
are not
malevolent right they they know what
they're doing so what do you do with
that in a society what do you think we
do with that I mean I want to defeat
their ideas but now they have raised
probably two generations of the next set
of clones
it's hard to say isn't it because
one thing that I find interesting about
America
that I don't feel about my own country
is
the pressure it feels like Americans are
under
like I hear the word fight a lot in
America you know we're fighting for your
rights we're fighting for Equal Pay
we're fighting for this we're fighting
for that and and people on the right you
know Stephen Crowder uses the word fight
a lot as well and I'm not having I'm not
throwing shade it's just because I mean
it's a totally rational response if
you've got a a well-oiled vast machine
that
is not trustworthy and is frankly
totalitarian I don't want to say
anything too mad for YouTube obviously
um yeah we're on Rumble it's okay oh
okay
so yeah um
he's more popular than Barack Obama's
well do you know
um if you've got this kind of well-old
machine that is
constantly trying to take over it's got
this voracious appetite it just will not
stop then what do you do you can't not
fight back against it but then you're in
some kind of social war where the
boundary lines are actually really
clearly drawn you know it's it's people
who are willing to be tolerant of others
and this radical left and the radical
left is a powerful force in your country
you know it's not nearly as powerful in
my country it's actually a lot more
Insidious in my country and so we I
don't feel that we're constantly in this
kind of social war whereas Americans it
feels that they're under a lot of
pressure you know and there's there's
and I can see on the faces of Americans
when I'm walking around man you know I
can see like they feel the world around
them is high stakes you know there's a
lot going on you know it's not just
moment I've been to lots of places in
America where you're seeing in Miami I
see a lot of happy people in Miami but
um I'm so hopped up on vitamin D down
here
but they're also
the people who are running everything
look kind of grim they you know their
lives are quite serious and they're
quite close to the edge they're a lot
close to the edge and they want to be
and I think all of this sort of just
combines to this
the kind of
I don't think it should be this way you
know I don't think it always was this
way because every American I met when I
was young was really happy-go-lucky it
was actually kind of adorable how kind
of just innocent Americans were right
yeah and it was just cheery and they
would be they they would have the same
kind of We're In It Together mentality
that we have in England but now you've
got the Democrats are like half the
country and or like a third of the
country and then the Republicans in the
third in the the exhausted Independence
in the middle yeah they they must be
exhausted look outside yeah you know but
you don't blame I can't blame for me
like look man I'm just tired of this
because it just feels like Americans are
constantly in the state of combat and
I don't envy it right would you say
that's partly because maybe we're just
kind of in our adolescence with all this
where you guys are an older Country and
it's it's just a different attitude this
is an excuse that Americans have been
making for a long time because actually
you're not that young a country yeah you
know as republics go 250 years is pretty
good actually you're probably getting to
the end of the life cycle of a republic
right the historically I'm bullish on
Florida so you know historically they
don't last that much longer and you
should be as well yeah um
but the it's I'm glad I'm not trapped in
a country with the Democrats right
because I wouldn't want to have to deal
with these people uh on a daily basis
and I wouldn't want them to be a facet
of my
local politics right so when you see the
the Federalist system working here and
now you're hearing you're bouncing
around into doing Cali in Texas and and
Florida
like you dig that like you see the
strength in that obviously oh yeah yeah
absolutely and I mean I think the
Santa's done a brilliant job with
Florida you know I've been following the
census career for about five or six
years now and he's been doing great and
going from strength strength we can talk
about the election thing in a minute
yeah sure
um but the but it's the fact that you're
trapped with these serpents in your
country it's like oh my God why does it
have to be that way why do we have to be
with people who literally don't respect
the legitimacy of anything that you do
they they literally hate you because of
your race and your gender and your
sexuality I mean not you but like you
know the average no they certainly hate
me no they still hate me yeah I don't
count no I'm what you said before I'm
the guy that walked away so I'm I'm
double apostate yeah yeah but like but
they genuinely hate you know it's a
genuine hate that animates them and it's
like right okay why would you want to be
trapped in a country where with a bunch
of people who just literally hate you
because this goes back to the very
nature of what it is to have a state in
the first place I mean Aristotle two and
a half thousand years ago thought there
couldn't be a state it's not based on
Goodwill and friendship he thought that
friendship was the basis of any
political organization and so now you
look at it you're like okay but those
people are trying to destroy us like
actively trying to destroy us they're
trying to get us shut down they're
trying to make us homeless they're
trying to make us destitute on the
streets like belisarius or something you
know like we're just gonna be on the
street in Rome blind and begging for
pennies you know that's where they would
have you
given the choice and I'm sorry okay why
Countryman think that way about me you
know that's what I think the average
American should be asking themselves say
hang on why should we have to live like
this with people like that who don't
respect that we are human beings
we're not just citizens we are your
countrymen you know there is meant to be
a bond that glowing bond between us and
you've severed that and called me a Nazi
you know and you want to try and destroy
me
that can't go on that just can't go on
forever and so at some point something
has to give and it has to be their
attitude towards you right right but the
damn shame of it and we before we're
beating a dead horse with this the damn
shame is that everyone that talks about
it from that perspective gets
annihilated oh yeah and and therein lies
the rub so it's like okay you wake up
and now congratulations they're doing it
to you and you either give up yeah or or
you end up like us which is not too bad
yeah no we've done fine yeah it's all
right and but all right well let's shift
for a second because actually speaking
of of doing fine you not only help me
when sort of I was waking up to this
stuff and everyone was saying you got to
talk to the Sargon of a car guy I don't
even know that I knew that you're do
were you even public at that point did I
know that your name was Carl was that
even a big probably not you were just
doing this thing okay but then a couple
years later you were also instrumental
in something else that happened sort of
accidentally because you and I were two
of the first political guys on patreon
and everyone remembers patreon was sort
of the first crowdfund monthly donation
site
and uh well I'll let you tell the story
but basically you got kicked off patreon
and it literally what happened
subsequently after that changed the
trajectory of my life so well there were
a bunch of white nationalists who really
didn't like the fact that I wasn't a
white nationalist and they were
attacking me and I kind of lost my cool
on a podcast it wasn't on my channel it
was on someone else's Channel it wasn't
on my patreon or anything like that so
that wait that's a really important
point it did not occur on your patreon
what you're about to say or your YouTube
channel is being funded on patreon so
you were in someone else's Channel okay
yes and they they were attacking me I
lost my call and I said things I
shouldn't have said right and I I'm more
than happy to accept that and looking
back at it I'm like oh but you didn't
say anything racist actually you you
said a word I was saying yeah but you
were also not using it pejoratively
really you were using it in like sort of
like a jokey oh yeah yeah it was it was
meant to be human you were being racist
in the nature of the way you were no no
and I wasn't saying it to a black person
or anything yeah that right yeah but but
in retrospect problem wise to have said
it I totally accept and I guess one of
these people had sent that to patreon
and patreon like oh well you're not
allowed to have your patreon anymore
okay but I didn't actually violate your
terms of service because I didn't post
any of that on the platform or nor was
it on my channel in fact the person
whose Channel it was on was a really
small YouTuber yeah so it's a tiny and
audio wasn't great like it was yeah
you'd have to really go out every way to
find it right but that was it and and
then there was a huge reaction to that
actually you know Sam Harris closed this
patreon and yeah you know Jordan
Peterson's think spot you set up locals
and it was just like it was a massive
thing it was really heartening to see it
as well yeah there were loads of people
like no actually you know you can't just
ruin people right you can't and you were
basically making your living from that
at that point right right so you have a
family you got four kids the whole thing
they just take you out basically
overnight and yeah for me I mean I
started Jordan and I we were working on
the think spot thing and Jordan
obviously got ill but that's what led to
locals which led obviously to a lot of
other success in Rumble so that you're
allowed to say whatever you want
which is pretty sweet
um but now you see it you referenced it
earlier now your government as we speak
is coming after uh Russell Brand and for
rumble put sending out a letter to
pressure them to say that a guy who just
has allegations against him should not
be able to make a living it's psychotic
but what we've been through this again
I mean at least in my case the
government didn't come for me you know
at least in my case it was just Jack
Conte over in California who decided no
I'll just take this executive action to
have a sitting MP right using the
authority of a government committee to
it wasn't just rumbly there was Tick
Tock Twitter and Facebook and who knows
why YouTube just you know we I don't
know that there's something that's
YouTube well YouTube did it already but
I think I guess what I guess YouTube was
just or they knew YouTube was going to
play ball right right yeah but the point
is that's I mean that's literally
against the Magna Carta that's the
against the very spirit and principle of
common law and it's staggering that that
person hasn't resigned yet right at the
time of recording that person hasn't
resigned I mean maybe they will have
done by the end of this but it's it's
just so beyond the pale and that's a
member of the conservative party you
know so they've they've brought into
because I mean I don't know what the
allegations against Russell Brand
whether they're true or not you know
it's a moot point it's irrelevant right
because okay well then if he's found
guilty there will be a punishment
prescribed under the law that great then
he can be punished you know as far as
I'm aware there are no charges against
them yet you know which makes this all
the worse because I mean he's he's
alleged it's really just a very very
aggressive rumor that is being spread
about him you know there are no legal
charges and I know a little something
about your tabloids they do make things
up they right is that fair to say I
watched the crown I know what they did
to Diana and then Martin Bashir the guy
who did it then became a huge star on
MSNBC in America the the the tabloids do
have a habit of having to attract a lot
yes
um the BBC as well in fact so yes it's
entirely possible these are not true and
uh or exaggerated and misinterpreted
something like this I don't know like I
said I have no idea
um but the point that you're making is
exactly right this is mad this is Way
Beyond The Pale
even if he is convicted for all the
things he that still doesn't mean he
should have his livelihood taken away
from him
it's so profoundly psychotic it would be
the equivalent of a guy who sells shoes
for a living going to a grocery store
and stealing an apple and then YouTube
saying to him you can't work anymore and
somehow the shoe store agreeing with it
like it really but but do you see this
as like like this is the fight more than
anything like the online fight now is
all we've got left right otherwise
everybody's going to turn into an NBC an
NPC it it it's
it's about the legitimacy of you as a
person right that's what it is so look
do I get to have an internet access
account on the internet do I get to
engage in society with everyone else or
should there be a particular privilege
class and everyone else literally
reduced to being a basket case you know
who can't get you know a bank account or
a YouTube account or whatever a Twitter
account you know is that a just society
and the conservative will say no
everyone actually is a kind of unique
human being who's a part of this
tapestry that we call society and even
okay if they do something wrong then we
have a law that prescribes what the
punishment for that wrongdoing is and
that's as far as it goes you know we
don't ruin them because of course the
conservatives think well people can
learn their mistakes learn from their
mistakes and change and actually it's
not right to destroy someone because
essentially it's kind of like a digital
death penalty that they're trying to
give Russell Brown it's like hey he
hasn't even been convicted and even if
he is guilty there are punishments for
it but what do you think the end game
for them would be not for a guy okay so
you scare the hell you maybe destroy
Russell Brand and you go for the people
that are backing him and the tech that
backs it and all that which is clearly
what this is about you know you know the
day before that the the Russell thing
went out there was a massive hit piece
about Rumble and the guardian then yeah
then yeah then the the uh the piece
comes out from the House of Commons like
it's just like it's just so obvious like
we've been through this before but what
do you think the end game is like okay
you can take out a Russell Brand you can
take out a Tucker Carlson you can take
out whoever you can take you can take
out Carl you can take out Dave but if
you take out millions of people who
can't participate in society like what
do they think is going to happen to
those people well maybe it's what they
want to happen to those people they're
definitely going for total control right
it's definitely about asserting a kind
of
internet-wide dominance so they are the
ones who have the authority to say yes
or no which is totally alien to the sort
of English-speaking experience right
because we're used to there being a
strong division between the state and
society and saying no look Society is
pluralistic we all get to have our own
little domains and Gardens and we get to
grow our little things and if they grow
then that's great and if they don't then
that's our fault and it's up to us right
and so Russell Brand again as for me the
classical liberal conservative I'm well
you know I'm not even a fan of Russell
Brand I remember Russell Brown being on
TV and it was really annoying really I
said when we covered this the other day
I was like I don't know that I've ever
seen a movie of his I I've interviewed
him and I like him a lot I really do now
and it's been fun seeing his Evolution
that you know we're referencing earlier
but in Britain Russell Brown's been
famous for about 25 years right the
before before we have the internet and
so you had four channels on TV right and
Russell Brand would be on one of them
and he'd be really annoying all right
because he was you know a young man who
was just a Brussels brand and so I was
never a fan right
um but the but the point is that's fine
I don't need to be a fan of his right I
don't need to be a fan I don't need to
have anything to do with him or anything
that he does it's meant to be a free
Society he can grow his YouTube channel
his Rumble Channel his Twitter whatever
he should be able to go out and do and
say whatever he likes and if I feel the
need to criticize him or contradict him
I should have my domain from where I can
do that as well and that's what a
pluralistic society actually looks like
but that of course is not what they're
creating and you are right what's
um what's the CEO of rumble's name uh
Chris pavlowski yeah I mean that
genuinely he's a great yeah he's a great
human being to turn around and give the
UK government just that kind of response
takes genuine courage because everyone
can see there is a kind of network of
power that is above the national level
at this point uh I don't know what
people want to call it like the world
economic Forum or anything like that
like but there is clearly some kind of
international network of power that is
left wing and it wants to have complete
managerial control of the society down
to the everything that you do from every
level it wants that and it's trying to
get it and that's why when um when there
were competitors to patreon that popped
up they instantly got pulled it's like
no we're not having that yeah and that's
what they're going to try and do with
Rumble yeah and that's my genuine fifth
fortunately rumbles on its own wires and
its own infrastructure which which makes
it much more of a threat you know even
Twitter
he's on Amazon AWS this is a problem
it's a massive problem but it goes even
further than that because we've seen
them debank people for example Nigel
farage very recently got his bank and
then there was a week can you talk about
that one for a little bit because I only
hit it on the show for a moment but
Raj who at one point was like
basically the most influential
politician in your country who I've had
the pleasure of having many drinks with
over time yeah and he the man likes to
he'll take a gin and tonic at any time
of the day but he has been so is he
officially debanked well okay so it was
a very big deal right it happened a few
months ago uh where the the bank is
called uh Coots I think it was called
and it's the bank that the queen uses
right and so you've got to have a
certain level of money in there and they
claim you have to have a certain level
of money in there but that's not really
true right you know obviously right you
know your Fortune's got them down but
one day they turned around and said well
actually we don't like Nigel farage and
we're going to close his bank and say
Nigel farage uh put out a piece on
Twitter and said well they're closing my
bank I don't know why and they said oh
it's just because for the you know the
oh you know don't have enough money in
there oh we've got excuses don't worry
about it but not your farage uh sent in
a freedom of information request two
Coots and legally they have to give him
the documents he's after and he gets one
document as minutes of a meeting where
they literally say Nigel farage is like
some sort of right-wing extremist and we
don't agree with his values and so we
don't want him banking with us and so
there was enough public pressure the
conservatives even the even the
conservatives have to be like okay it's
not on for you to just take people's
bank accounts away from them because of
course in the modern era you need that
to exist and so Nigel farage actually
got his bank account back he won this
battle right and so and that's great
it's always nice to have the win but
again why are we trapped in
civilizations where there are people
trying to ruin us you know so so would
you say the answer to that simply is
parallel everything I mean that's
basically where I'm coming to it's not a
great answer it's not a great answer
especially in America because we are we
are Multicultural in the best sense of
it that was the purpose of the country
and they're using it against us in a way
but do you see a better alternative than
that that will just like-minded people
will just have different everything
schools coffee shops internet yeah I
didn't say it's good but I'm just asking
you for a better alternative for the
future that would be I think the
undesirable alternative that we would be
routed out of our own civilization and
then be forced like the productive
people that we are to rebuild from the
rubble right well by the way ours will
be much better in the end oh yeah for
sure absolutely for sure but there'll be
a lot of pain points which is why why
they'll declare war on us because they
literally will they'll see what we're
doing
through virtue and look at the vice that
they've been spreading and say okay but
we need some of what you've got it's
like well you're not having it that is
one of my major fears that if Biden wins
again or the Democrats are in charge
that there will start being a secession
movement that I think most likely even
though I don't want to give it energy it
will probably be somewhat just right
from let's say Florida Texas uh
Tennessee couple other states and
they'll be fine leaving yeah the other
guys are never going to let the Cali's
never going to let Florida walk nope
without answering who knows where that
goes and I I I I I I I'm completely
agree with you I don't like giving
energy by talking about the idea of
secession because no no no no
we we have lost far too much ground to
the Communists we need to start taking
some stuff back right we need to stop we
why aren't we on the attack you know
everything good and just is in our favor
here right like we are not the ones who
are doing terrible things children we
are not the ones who are running the
economy we are not the ones who are just
you you can see the quality of their
civilization degrading around them right
their planes are going to fall out of
the sky because they're going to hire
the wrong people and their doctors won't
be qualified yeah exactly right the the
that's exactly right the quality of
their civilization is degrading things
are going to start failing how is it
that we're losing to these people right
and so basically we have to essentially
Harden our hearts and say just no you're
just you're wrong on everything and
we're not going to accept your arguments
on anything and people vote for us
because we are right and we can prove it
we're right on morality we're right on
economics we're right on practical
matters we're right on just everything
that we're saying and they're wrong on
everything you know in fact they're not
just wrong they're evil they are
actually evil and they're trying to ruin
your life and that's how we need to
start framing it sorry look at them look
at them they're giving needles to drug
addicts what kind of Maniacs are you
that God you know don't even talk about
what they're doing to Children what kind
of Maniacs are these people you know
they're they're stealing your money and
it's like no I'm not well soon enough
they're going to literally be stealing
your kids I don't know if you've heard
what's going on in California I don't
think if you don't affirm if you don't
Affair I mean it's the least affirming
thing you could possibly do and they
already do this in Canada where it's
like literally the state can justify
stealing your children I mean there'll
probably be a time in the future where
it'll be considered wild that the state
can find reasons to take your children
away from you you know if when we win
you know the bond between parent and
child will be considered inviolable so
do you see it in a weird way that that
in America that our federalism in a
bizarre way is a weakness too because a
million people fled Kelly that's a
million people who probably would have
fought for a lot of those things myself
included right big time campaigner to
get rid of Newsome but I'm here
fortifying this place now so the Divide
because of our federalism will increase
where as you were saying you guys kind
of resurrected your own labor party
because you've got nowhere to go yeah
that that's an odd position for us to be
that's interesting as well because also
the the
give secessionism a kind of life as well
right well that's an option we could
take it's like yeah but you don't want
that option you know you don't want to
break up the United States what you want
is to defeat the left and completely
route them out of all the institutions
you know and so you've got to start
really thinking about how are we going
to do that you know we need a proper
ground game we need to literally you
know take printouts of look at what is
happening where they are look at what
they're doing we are going to do the
opposite of this and you need to start
literally pulling people away from them
and being like no they're bad people
they are bad what they're doing is bad
it is immoral they lie to you about the
morality and they're going to ruin this
country as they've ruined the states
they occupy at the moment and so you
need to actually start taking things
back from that it's not enough to just
simply say okay we'll just try and get
away from them maybe it's morally
neutral no they're evil and they have to
be stopped
so let's spend our last few minutes
discussing the Trump DeSantis thing
because I think you might offer some
interesting Insight on that you know my
position here in the Free State of
Florida I don't have to twist or contort
myself to defend to Santas he happens to
be more conservative than me on certain
issues I was fine with the 15-week
abortion band we had here he went for
six but I can accept that he's the chief
executive of the state with the super
majority and did but okay fine
everything else you get you get all the
good stuff I don't have to repeat it to
you uh where do you sit on all of this I
hate it hate the conflict I hate
everything yeah I do too I take no
pleasure in what I'm doing when I have
to criticize trump it drives me crazy
right because I like I said I've
supported scientists for a number of
years now because he was an amazing
governor and he and he still is an
amazing governor and he's really led the
way in legislating against left-wing
morality you know he I mean he's really
got a fantastic track record of
absolutely crushing them and just
increasing his majority by going no no
look we're right they're wrong I'm good
they're bad and we're gonna do these
things and look and now I mean what's it
now like 65 approval rating oh yeah it's
three years right and so it's like okay
fantastic but they're also kind of
immutable laws of politics that
unfortunately I think DeSantis has kind
of failed to
um not predict but fail to observe right
and that's the the first one is is from
like Robert Greene's books the 48 of
power which is uh never outshine the
master right Trump
is a more veteran Statesman than him by
virtue of being a the president and
being older right now I'm completely in
agreement with all those people to say
look do we have to have such old people
as the presidential candidates I totally
totally agree but you are kind of in
that position and I think that people
understand the world through stories
and part of the reason that I want it to
be Trump and I think a lot of trump
supporters feel this way because I mean
you know whether you whether you like it
or not he's like 50 points up in the
polls right so he is crushing it
um and I I've got many criticisms of the
way Trump conducts himself conducts his
campaign and I and I think the reason
none of these criticisms land is because
actually we're not in the realm of
political policy making and things like
that when we talk about this yeah I
think what's happening to America is a
genuine spiritual crisis and I think
actually Trump is the only guy who can
kind of resolve that spiritual crisis
because I think they screwed him in 2020
and I think Trump needs to have his sort
of Return of the King moment when he
comes back and and it has to be Trump
because they hate him more than anything
and they did this to him right and
that's why it has to be Trump and this I
think his base feels that way I think
the average sort of you know middle
American who's just like you know it's
Trump or die I don't care you know and
then and I really and I'm honestly I'm
genuinely on on this train with them
yeah no it's Trump because of f them
because F them that's why you know it's
so interesting because I'm with you on
so much Earth and I think it's a
spiritual crisis and they screw they're
in the process of screwing him in all
these Federal cases and all of that
stuff my criticism has been and I wonder
I want to know your thoughts on this
because you obviously care about truth
and you care about decency and
everything else I think had he not gone
so scorched Earth with DeSantis that I'd
have an easier time with this right now
like I just see the guy that I think is
the best that is the guy we've been
waiting for that in in any other uh year
we'd be like wait a minute we have a guy
who did everything we could have asked
sorry but that's it in any other year
yeah right that's the thing
we may not we in a weird way we almost
don't deserve him I I can sort of accept
that no no it's what it is is just
Prudence right it's like if I were
DeSantis I would have been like I'm
gonna go for it just not yet right
because Trump can only go for it this
last time really because otherwise he'll
be too old but we'll have two
um
presidential uh
runs so he can't go for a third right so
DeSantis is a young man still he's about
my age actually isn't he I think he's 44
or 45 years yeah so like he should have
been like I'll just wait four years is
the inherent problem also that if Trump
truly believes that the election was
stolen and clearly you believe at least
to some extent that that is the case by
the way Millions tens of millions of
people do believe that at least at some
level that why wouldn't they just steal
it again has he done anything to have
them right why hasn't he brought that
case forward I I need him to say that
well here's what I'm gonna do yeah so it
doesn't happen all over again yeah um
did you read the Time magazine article
uh
basically saying how we oh fortified the
election yeah was it time was it it was
it the Atlantic no no it was a tough
time it was time yeah that we didn't
they're right they there were systems in
places
right and it's like okay
but one thing that you can take away
from reading Max I read that with great
interest
was how much effort this was for them
right there was a lot of effort and it's
because they just had four years of
trump four years of you know orange
Hitler destroying the entire country by
making everyone wealthy and happy and
prosperous and
ending a lot of problems around the
world and making sure that people
respected America as a superpower again
that is unconscionable you can't have
any of that right and so they felt
deeply oppressed and so they were very
very motivated
to do the things they did right they
were very motivated to do it I'm not
sure that same energy is there this time
because they've had four years of Biden
ruining everything for them and actually
things were tangibly better under Trump
everyone had more money things were
going better people felt but you don't
think the Elite Class is still feeling
pretty good right now I don't know
they're like well I don't know I don't
know or whoever is pulling the strings
there yeah like do they seem like
they're happy they they seem afraid to
me actually you know usually with any
kind of elite class uh a sort of a cruel
exercise of power as a sign of weakness
rather than strength because it you know
you've got the power but you really
shouldn't be using it you should be able
to persuade those people underneath you
to do the things that you think should
be done because that shows you've got
moral legitimacy if you've got to
literally like start crushing people
like they are now then it shows actually
they're afraid and they they think
they're wiping out threats but whenever
you do that anything that was connected
to what you just whacked is like oh well
that wasn't good and you know you keep
doing that you you create a larger large
body of people who are just
okay you guys seem mad and we're afraid
of you now right and so it's just bad
blood it's bad vibes it's negativity and
so I'm not convinced that the Democratic
Elite Class actually feels good about
the position that they're in
I mean they must know that I mean almost
all Democrats know the Biden's a
terrible terrible candidate he's
terrible president yeah and what we're
going to we're going to go through all
this effort again to get that guy back
do we want that guy actually you know
are we so wedded you know because well
maybe it won't be that guy that's a
whole that's a whole other topic maybe
but either way it's the same agenda as
well right and so I I just I wonder how
much of the sort of the pressure that
because I mean we haven't heard about
Trump for four years people forget it
was non-stop wall-to-wall media coverage
of how Nazi the Cheeto Hitler is is
doing this terrible thing he's tweets of
this terrible thing today right all time
low black
Hispanic unemployment in reality
everything was actually going great for
everyone that there was light at the end
of the tunnel for everyone right things
were genuinely going well
and now I don't think anyone can say
there's light in the end of the tunnel
right I mean look at the price of
everything you know look how difficult
everything seems to be look how much
pressure everyone seems to be under like
really you've got the energy to make
sure that the guy who made everything
great is not coming back like I don't I
mean I'm not saying it can't happen I'm
not saying it won't happen right you
know I definitely think it happened in
2020 but I'm I'm it was just very
obvious from the Time magazine article
that this took a lot of work and you had
to
have the people willing to do the work
you know to spend all the energy see I
mean they got paid but it's still like
you've got a it's a lot of
morale that you have to have to do this
right I'm not sure that's there this
time and maybe it is Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe it'll be maybe I'll eat these
words sort of thing but I'm not sure
they've got the energy for another
fortification and honestly I just really
think it has to be Trump I just yeah I
really wanted to be Trump that finally
crushes them and then DeSantis would be
the perfect man to step in and go yep
okay we've routed them we've got the
winning formula right because everyone I
mean there are so many complaints about
Trump's first term right and it and even
Trump when he was on Tucker Carlson he
was like well I was kind of naive about
this you know I didn't realize all of
the establishment would be against all
the institutions would essentially lock
arms and keep me out you know and maybe
Trump in the next Administration will
legislate a lot harder against those
political opponents and in fact after
the mugshot maybe he definitely will
but DeSantis would be a brilliant guy to
come in after that and going look we
know what works we know how we're going
to win I've got a blueprint of it
Trump's just done whatever he's just
done we know that we're righteous and
we're decent and we're creating a better
world in what we do and I there would be
no conflict whatsoever because Trump
could then just go as the outgoing
president DeSantis is our boy he's on
let's let's carry on the magra agenda
let's carry on making this country great
let's make the world great we've got
this you know but instead they're
fighting and it's so interesting though
because you're making a more com what
you just said which I actually agree
with almost all of it is a more
compelling case than I think Trump has
made for himself I know I think actually
you're well clearly you're far more
eloquent in the Expo in the decent
explanation of why it works where he's
doing still the name calling and the
games and it's like I don't want to be
part of that anymore that's what I'm
saying you just made a case that is
completely decent and also proves that I
have not lost all of my classical
liberal beliefs because because even
though I'm still a DeSantis guy I let
you say it right here on my show could
there be anything more truly liberal
than that and that's something I'm a
DeSantis guy yeah I've been praising on
the podcast yeah you know every day we
do the podcast and then you know every
day DeSantis will have done something
else great and we're just like brilliant
the Santa's just legislated against this
what they wanted they've taken an L
brilliant and again and again and again
and it's he shouldn't have been
challenging the the master that's the
problem because you know there is a
hierarchy of these things Trump was the
president he's the guy the story is
about at the moment you know and then
Trump needs to come to the sort of
natural conclusion of his hero's journey
defeat the villain and then ride off
into the sunset you know go back to
Florida and and you know have a go to
dinner parties and do whatever he wants
and just instead he's sniping at the
sentence and I agree you know he's not
covering himself in glory in this you
know but DeSantis is not doing great in
the polls compared to Trump because I
think everyone feels this you know in
this sort of genuine conservative way so
hang on a second it's just not your time
yet you know so I I think whoever
advised DeSantis to go for it now I just
think that was a miscalculation you know
it should be like you're a young man
you're a young man keep making Florida
amazing you know get get yourself
another five points up in the approval
rating in Florida which I don't doubt
that he can do yeah and if it's only
four years you're a young man you've got
the time then you can do and then
everyone would be behind DeSantis as I
have said many times if this all ends
with Trump as my president and the Santa
says my governor
Carly it was a pleasure seeing you again
I'm glad things are going so well and uh
I hope you make it through America
without getting too depressed because
you know you're in Florida Yeah well
yeah I'm in Florida so I'm having a
great time but uh no I mean everyone
everyone is just so nice and I get to
see loads of people who I know from the
internet uh in real life and they're all
lovely and I'm it's great to be here the
internet in real life how about it good
to seeing you man if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell